Marvel isn't just telling a story in their
films, they're creating a whole universe.
So if a character makes even the smallest
cameo in a movie, chances are there's a lot
more to them than we're seeing on-screen.
Here's a spoiler-filled look at some characters
in Thor: Ragnarok with more meaning than you
might've realized.
Valkyrie
Movie fans around the world were thrilled
when they learned that the Hulk would be teaming
up with the God of Thunder in Thor: Ragnarok.
But comic book fans were even more excited
to see the Hulk team up with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe's newest superheroine, Valkyrie.
That's because Hulk and Valkyrie were friends
and teammates for years in the pages of the
classic Marvel series The Defenders, which
also featured Doctor Strange and the Sub-Mariner.
While the Defenders name has been poached
by Marvel's TV division, seeing Valkyrie,
Hulk, and Doctor Strange in the same movie
keeps the dream of a big-screen Defenders
reunion alive, and further opens the door
for the eventual appearance of Namor in the
MCU.
Grandmaster
Known across the galaxies as the Grandmaster,
En Dwi Gast is more than just a guy who loves
games and bloodsport.
He's also one of the Elders of the Universe,
which, in Marvel Comics, is a group of immortal
beings of immense power who are traditionally
the guardians of the Infinity Stones.
Like his fellow Elder, the Collector — who
was played by Benicio del Toro in Guardians
of the Galaxy — The Grandmaster is likely
to make another appearance when Thanos finally
rears his head in Avengers: Infinity War.
Skurge the Executioner
Hela's minion Skurge the Executioner has a
long and curious history in the comics.
A longtime villain and adversary to Thor,
Skurge eventually redeemed himself in an epic
storyline, where he held off the armies of
Hell armed with a pair of machine guns in
order to save Thor and a group of innocent
mortals fleeing from Hela.
That part made it into the film.
But for most of his existence, it wasn't Hela
that Skurge was associated with, but rather
his one true love, the immortal Asgardian
sorceress known as the Enchantress.
Both an enemy and occasional ally of Thor,
the Enchantress is arguably the most important
character from Thor comics who hasn't yet
appeared in the MCU.
The appearance of Skurge in Thor: Ragnarok
suggests that might be on the verge of finally
changing.
Korg
The rocklike Korg belongs to a species that
has actually been teased twice before in the
MCU, first in Thor: The Dark World, and then
again in a quick Easter egg in Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol. 2.
And the character contains another secret,
as the CGI-created gladiator was played by
Thor: Ragnarok director Taika Waititi himself.
But the real Easter egg behind Korg is a deep
cut from the very dawn of Marvel Comics: he's
part of the alien race originally known as
the "Stone Men from Saturn," who Thor fought
in his very first comic book appearance in
1962's Journey into Mystery #83.
In fact, in the comics, Korg himself is one
of the very alien invaders Thor battled in
his origin story.
How cool is that?
Miek
Poor little Miek is played purely for comic
relief in Thor: Ragnarok, but in the comics
he's a much darker figure.
A lot of the plot of Thor: Ragnarok is borrowed
from the "Planet Hulk" comic book story, in
which Hulk leads a band of fellow gladiators
on the planet Sakaar in a revolution.
Hulk then becomes ruler of the planet, which
is where things take a sinister turn for Miek.
Unsatisfied with the new peace Hulk has ushered
in, Miek is complicit in a plot that leads
to the death of Hulk's wife and child, sending
Hulk on a vengeful rampage across the galaxy.
It's only later that Hulk discovers the base
treachery of his supposed friend.
He doesn't seem so cute and goofy now, does
he?
Topaz
The Grandmaster's right-hand woman originally
wasn't even a Marvel character at all.
Instead, she was created at Malibu Comics
as Queen Topaz, the ruler of a race of alien
amazons.
Eventually she ended up as a superhero on
Earth.
After Marvel bought Malibu and folded some
of its characters into the Marvel Universe,
she was summoned by the Grandmaster to be
a pawn in a contest with Loki, losing a fight
against Crystal and Black Widow of the Avengers.
Topaz is the first Malibu character to make
it into the Marvel Cinematic Universe, opening
the door for characters like Hardcase, Firearm,
and Prime to potentially make the jump to
the big screen as well.
Beta Ray Bill
Eagle-eyed observers may have noticed that
one of the busts adorning the outside of the
Grandmaster's tower is none other than Beta
Ray Bill himself.
Who's that, you ask?
Well, you know that inscription on Thor's
hammer that says whoever is worthy can lift
the hammer and gain the power of Thor?
In the comics, Beta Ray Bill shocked Thor
and fans alike, by proving himself worthy
and lifting the hammer.
He became as powerful as Thor himself, and
earned the Thunder God's trust as his sworn
brother from an alien mother.
Beta Ray Bill has been a fan-favorite ever
since he first debuted in the early '80s,
so the fact that the film acknowledged his
existence is enough to send hardcore Thor
fans over the moon.
It means that somewhere out there in the MCU,
Beta Ray Bill exists.
Now it's just a matter of actually putting
him into a movie, instead of just a statue
of his head.
Are you listening, Marvel?
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!